make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to beyond omega-level a
series of videos where we cover the
powers and feats of some of the most
powerful beings throughout the entirety
of comic books and in this video we're
going to be focusing on net cron now
nekron was created by Mike Barr Lynde
wine and Joe statin and made his debut
in June of 1981 in tales of the Green
Lantern Corps number 2 now Necron rules
over a region of the afterlife called
the land of the unliving where souls
wait until making their journey to
either hell or the Silver City which is
basically DC's version of heaven and so
Necron pretty much rules over what is
the equivalent of purgatory in the DC
Universe and his powers are fueled by
souls of every individual to ever die
now our first introduction of Necron
actually centers around another
character named Crona who's a scientist
on the planet Malta's the home of one of
the oldest traces of intelligent life in
the universe
Crona creates a device that allows him
to see the beginning of time despite a
warning that doing so would bring about
disaster and so after allowing Crona to
see a glimpse of the creation of the
universe the machine that he had built
explodes which leads to the creation of
the multiverse in the antimatter
universe thereby releasing evil into
existence Crona was then punished by
being turned into pure energy and he
just roamed throughout all of creation
without a physical body until he finds
his way to the land of the unliving
while he's there necron restores prone
into a physical form but this time as an
immensely powerful undead beam necron
then he gives cronic command over a
legion of undead soldiers and tasked him
with killing the guardians of the
universe and hopes that doing so will
allow him to pass into the living world
and so Crona manages to kill a few other
guardians of the universe which are
actually members of crona's own race who
left the planet Malta's following his
failed experiment and relocated to the
planet OA who would go on to create the
Green Lantern Corps as a team of
Universal policemen and in killing some
of the Guardians the rift between his
realm and the realm of the living grows
but is eventually closed and Necron was
defeated by Hal Jordan and the souls of
the Green Lantern's that had died
fighting his undead forces and so after
that net Kron appears sparingly
throughout the next couple of decades
with the most significant appearance
being in Kalvin atom number 42 which
explains that Necron represents death as
the ultimate opponent that one must
defeat if they're ever going to reenter
the realm of the living after their
death this is in contrast to the other
avatars of death in the DC Universe the
black racer wood represents the
navigability of death and death of The
Sandman series that represents the
merciful release of death but necrons
most prominent storyline is 2009 s
blackest night which sees him try to
destroy all life in the universe by
bringing a whole bunch of dead
superheroes back to life
and this is where we see the
introduction of the Black Lantern Corps
into the DC mythos and we see necron
being resurrected when the black
Lantern's central power battery is fully
charged and so those you guys who were
curious if you want to know what happens
in this story
I've actually got a full playlist on
blackest night and brightest day and I
need to finish that playlist with all
the other Green Lantern stories but
you'll find like blackest night in there
and all that kind of good stuff it's
like three hours long so you should go
check it out it's kind of insane now one
thing that blackest night does is that
at week's necrons origin a bit by
revealing that Necron was created by the
universe as a counterbalance to the
emotional spectrum of light which had
thrown off the balance of light and
darkness and required the creation of a
necron to serve as a guardian of the
darkness itself and so with that being
said the question becomes what are
necrons powers well he can create bolts
of dark lightning and fire from his
hands and these bolts have been shown to
be extremely potent in one instance the
bolts killed one of the guardians of the
universe and in another they damaged
Wonderwoman despite being blocked by her
powerful enchanted gauntlets as necron
causes the deaths of others he becomes
more powerful himself he's a being of
extreme durability and is almost
impossible to harm he's taken multiple
blows from formidable enemies such as
Captain Atom and Wonder Woman without
taking any damage whatsoever was unfazed
by the heat vision of cyborg superman
and was unharmed by an energy attack
from the anti-monitor one of the most
powerful beings in the entirety of DC
Comics nekron is widely thought to be
immortal as he's the embodiment of death
so long as death exists Necron is widely
thought to be immortal as he's the
embodiment of death and so long as death
exists nekron will exist as well
something else a point out here is that
Necron proved to be unaffected even by
the spectre the personification of
divine vengeance and one of the
strongest characters in the DC Universe
not only was he immune to the specters
judgment but he was able to banish the
spectre from his presence which in and
of itself is a testament to just how
powerful Necron is now Necron can also
manipulate matter and energy as well as
being able to drain the quantity flow of
energy that powers Captain Atom from him
and was able to empower Crona with the
ability to deke
prease the size of the universe by 1/6
in addition to matter an energy nekron
can also manipulate souls as he did when
he created an army of the dead that were
trapped in the land of the unliving and
can also control those who have been
revived after dying as he did with
several superheroes in the blackest
night event he's able to warp reality
demonstrating his ability to rapidly
advance the age of his victims and
removes the anti-monitor from the
universe banishing him back to the
antimatter universe itself and of course
being death incarnate
Metron can bring about the end of any
body by simply touching them so yeah I
think it's pretty clear that Necron is a
beyond omega-level character it's
ridiculous how powerful he is but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain it make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]